as you're gonna see just like all of
these right the way to prove this is by
using all of the laws all these rules
that we've established already so here's
why we're gonna do it one base a of B
where this guy over here log base a of B
suppose we did not know that it was
equal to this just suppose right so
we're trying to work out what is it
equal to I'm just gonna give it a name
I'm gonna call it okay
all right like so I'm just going to give
that a new name and then what can I do
with this well you know how you went
from here an exponential equation and
you rewrote that same equation as a log
equation right that's something that you
did I can do the same thing but in
Reverse over here right this is
currently a log equation how would you
rewrite this as an exponential equation
and I think about how you did it before
there's a base here what does it become
in the new equation I think back to how
we did it the base here becomes the base
in the new equation yeah I'm gonna have
a power because I'm about to write an
exponential equation where's the power
come from it's K very good see how see
how this zero right
snuck over to the opposite side well
this is thinking up into the power like
so what's that equal to that's B right
that's the only number that I have left
it's got to be equal to something okay
so I pulled the argument out it's over
on the right hand side now now here I'm
gonna pull a bit of a rabbit out of a
hat okay you see how I'm trying to get
to this right I'm trying to get some
common log base right so what I'm gonna
do is see how this is an equation I can
do the same thing to both sides and it
will stay equal do you agree with that
so long as I do the same thing to both
sides here's what I'm gonna do take logs
of both sides this is my new base that
I'm introducing if I took log on this
side I'm gonna take log on this side are
you okay with that like I did this a
it's like adding two to both sides or
dividing both sides by five I just took
logs of both sides so far so good
okay now we're very very close I wonder
if like the jigsaw pieces are connecting
in your brain yet which
law I've got it on the board you got in
your page which law can I use how now to
simplify this have a look at it how can
I simplify this thing I can use this
last one right the power law right this
power up here where can it go I can take
this and write it see where I had it
before I can write it at the front do
you see that okay so I'm gonna switch
this guy out the front like so now we're
almost there
do you reckon you guys can tell me what
to do next think about where I'm trying
to end up this is my goal just want to
try to prove what could I do both sides
that might be helpful here I can divide
what can I divide both sides by I'll
divide both sides by this guy you see
that you see how that's supposed to be
on my denominator over here so I'm gonna
divide both sides by log base X of a
that leaves one on the left-hand side
okay very good just by itself over here
I've got that fraction that exact
fraction right log base X of B log base
X of a there's only one last thing to do
what what was K in the beginning like I
introduced that right it's this guy
that's what we began with that thing
that I didn't know what it was equal to
well now I do know what it's equal to
that log base a of B is this which is a
familiar law which we stated before but
now you know why okay so the key part if
you want to highlight this for yourself
the key part is this one here see here
you had to use this law that we
established earlier and the rest of it
it's just a bit of sort of rearrangement
with your algebra okay so these are your
laws and how to use them but I don't do
one last thing do we have time yeah we
do okay I don't want you to just know
the laws I want you to feel that they
are true so I bought a little prop with
me okay it's some before you asked right
it's not what you think it is can I ask
you underneath where you've written all
of those all of those rules can I just
ask you to write a pair of equations for
me this pair of equations
okay I'm gonna pull this over here so
you guys cannot quite see it's on the
inside that'll do all right
okay do you have that pair of equations
just the numbers up here the ones i've
written in red yep okay here's what I
want to try and do I want to take all of
this algebraic soup and try and turn it
into a metaphor in your head that I hope
actually makes sense of what's going on
okay can you look at these two rate
equations the ones that I just asked you
to write down these are the same sets of
numbers here - 532 here I'm looking at
them from an exponential point of view
and here I'm looking at them from a
logarithmic point of view here's the
metaphor I want you to have in your head
okay I want you to imagine you have a
box and when you put stuff in the box it
just makes that stuff grow just makes it
get bigger and bigger and bigger okay
now what this exponential equation is
asking is if you've got a box and like
say for example it's a doubling box okay
and you leave it in you leave that you
take something object right and you
leave it inside the box for like say
five minutes okay it'll double every
minute that's what this box does it just
doubles things every minute because it's
like Star Trek or something right so if
you leave it in for five minutes
how BIG's it going to become answer
it'll be 32 times bigger than it was
before okay whereas this is saying hey
if you've got your same box right and it
doubles things I want to end up 32 times
bigger than when I started so my
question now is how long is it going to
take how many minutes will it take me
pre-listing the box to understand like
to get to that size and the answer is
there's like five minutes that makes
sense
so this is a question of size and this
is a question of time right so I want
you to actually picture this right you
take an object then you say oh and make
sure it working out do this follow there
we go okay you take your object and you
put it inside right you wait you one
minute and then after one minute you're
like oh okay I've got two of them right
that's what this thing does make sense
you wait another minute you put your
stuff back inside right after the next
minute how big do you expect it to be
after another minute right
you hopefully expect them I really
didn't arrange this very well you
hopefully expect there to be for you
with me okay we decide we're just gonna
wait for a while right you're gonna wait
for a while you're gonna wait five whole
minutes but every minute what's
happening he's doubling right which is
why by the end you're like okay I got
thirty two pencils in here and some and
some of these stuff that keeps things
dry okay so do you get the picture okay
now why am i laboring this point I now
want you to come back to these things
these lines here I want you to see
pencils why this works okay let me put
some numbers on this and give you an
example right just think about this for
a second I know you already know what
it's equal to but I want you to think
about in terms of this right you've got
this doubling machine it's doubling
machine and the question I'm now asking
you is not about how big things get but
how long it takes to get to that right
here's my question how long does it take
you to be well what you started with
your original science how long's that
take you in the machine it doesn't take
you any time at all you're already that
size does that make sense so it takes
you zero time to get there okay how long
does it take you in your doubling
machine to get to double your size takes
you one minute right because that's what
it does every time unit it will double
okay think about this if you have your
doubling machine right and you waited
some amount of time until you were like
say four times bigger yeah and then you
waited a bit longer until you were for
example eight times bigger and you did
those in sequence this time Plus this
time how much bigger are you going to be
by the end you grew four times bigger in
the first instance and then you put the
you're like needs longer right so you
put it in it got eight times bigger
again so now at the end how much bigger
is it it's it's 32 times bigger right
it's that amount of time are you with me
that's how many minutes two minutes
that's how many minutes three minutes
and this is the five that you determine
are you with me okay now let me really
push on you okay think about this I
haven't written this as a rule but if
you're thinking with me you understand
the metaphor you'll get it right
got my doubling machine now my question
is how long until I'm half the size I am
down
how long until I'm half the size I am
now this thing doubles every minute that
you wait right so if I go into the
future what's happening I'm just getting
more and more of these things right
they're getting bigger right so if you
want to get smaller you don't go into
the future do when we use smaller answer
in the past before this actually started
right so think about how we can use our
rules here okay log base two I can write
this as su ^ what it's a half su ^ think
think think go all the way back set
against right minus one do you agree
write negative indices mean you get a
fraction right but look isn't this where
if I written it isn't this this
situation right you see I've got a power
there what can I do with that minus one
where can it go it can come out the
front right so this is minus log base 2
of the number that's left behind right
that's in the eye you're ain't told me
that that is one you have to go one
minute in the past that's when you were
half the size that you are now because
that's what this thing does right it
doubles things so when were you half the
size one minute ago does that make sense
so when you think about all of these
things the metaphor you should have in
your mind is time these are things that
are growing exponentially
real fast right logs are about changing
the perspective on the same reality
we're not thinking about how big it gets
we're thinking about how long okay